hey what's going on folks this will be
another spoiler video but it's also
going to be kind of a prediction video
based on all the evidence that I've
gathered during the production of season
seven and this may end up being a short
video because this one's going to be
about the fate of Uncle Benjen during
season seven and Uncle Benjen is one of
those mysterious characters that we have
only seen in maybe five total episodes
out of the entire series which there's
60 episodes and just to give you a quick
recap that way all the other stuff I say
makes sense
Benton Stark is brother to Ned Stark and
he was the first Ranger of the Nights
Watch and ever since he left Castle
black in season one he was pretty much
just been a ghost
most who presumed was already dead but
thankfully during season six we found
out uncle Benjamin was in fact still
alive
kinda while bran Meera and Hodor was at
the three-eyed Ravens cave so that brain
could learn how to harness his powers so
that he could become the new three-eyed
Raven brain decided to take it upon
himself to enter the weirwood net by
himself which is when bran entered a
vision with the night's king in the
night's king actually saw Brandon
reached out and grabbed him leaving a
mark on Brandon's arm that allowed the
night's king to track him wherever he
was including the three-eyed Ravens cave
and until then it had magical powers
that could keep the others out but with
brains mark he could now enter and
that's when the cave became under attack
but thanks to Hodor holding the door
brain and mir were able to escape but
that only gave them a little bit of a
head start and eventually the whites
were able to catch up but in steps Uncle
Benjen to save the day and after Uncle
Benjen was able to get them to safety
he told branimir that the three-eyed
raven sent for him that's how he found
them and came to save them which may be
true but I think he may know exactly
when to show up because he is receiving
the same signal all the other whites are
receiving from the night's king which is
how they know when and where to attack
benjin is no longer human nor is he a
full white and after Benjamin was
stabbed by an ice sword the children of
the force were able to save him
from fully turning over to the dark side
by sticking a blade of dragonglass
directly into his heart just like they
did with the night's king but I think
benjin is still able to know when the
night's king or the whites are ready to
attack I think by him being half turned
he can pick up on their movements or
signal all the same which is how he knew
bran was in trouble and I think during
season seven that's how he's going to
know John is in trouble now that benjin
is a half-white he can no longer cross
the wall so the only way he is going to
be able to come in contact with any of
the characters again is if the wall
comes down or some of those people come
up north and according to the leak that
came out back in October we learned that
John and his SEAL team 6 are going to go
north to hunt for a white so he can take
the white south to all the other Lords
to convince them of the threat so he can
get help to fight them and in that
leakage said during episode six
John will go north of the wall with
Jorah Horman and some other characters
to get this weight but he's going to
become under attack on a frozen lake by
the night's king in his army but that's
when Danny arrives and saves everyone
but John
but just like benjin did with brand he's
going to come in just in time and save
John but most people believe that this
is complete fan fiction even I did it
first until I started looking at the
evidence that is came out during the
filming of this season they have already
built a set with a frozen lake just like
the leek said in John tormund Jorah and
the Hound
have already showed up in Belfast to
film this scene north of the wall just
like the league said an Allen Taylor who
is directing episode 6 which is the
exact episode the leek said all this
stuff would take place in has arrived
and already been hanging out with these
guys as well just like the league said
and now when this new photo which is a
brand new spoiler photo Uncle Benjen has
arrived and he's already hanging out
with these guys so they can film this
scene and this is such an odd group of
characters to be hanging out together
but it's just like the league said would
happen so I definitely think this is
going to happen
think John and company will go north to
find a white to take south as proof but
the night's king is going to show up
first before they can leave and attack
them and I think benjin will receive the
same signal he did when brain was under
attack and show up just in time to save
John by giving him his horse to escape
but benjin is going to be swarmed by the
whites and killed and I think benjin is
eventually going to become a full white
or maybe even more since he has the
Stork blood I do not think this is going
to be the last time that we see uncle
Benjen I think with him having stark
blood
I think the night's king could use him
for something more and when that wall
comes down in the undead army marches
south I think we will see benjin again
and I think we will eventually get an
emotional scene to where John or one of
the other Starks have to actually kill
Uncle Benjen and it's not going to be
because they want to but it's going to
be because they have to because
regardless if they love him or not if
he's a full white they're going to have
to take him down but that's what I think
guys with all the evidence that is
coming out I can no longer deny it even
I've talked about it with you guys and
you know said I believe that I still
kind of was in denial about it but I no
longer can be there's more and more
evidence keeps coming out that continues
to prove it right so to me I'm going to
completely agree with it and I'd
probably bet money on it but it's still
up for you guys to speculate we can
comment and chat about it and still
discuss it if you don't believe it
that's completely fine but I wanted to
put it all together for you and put it
out and see what you guys think anyway
either way if you disagree I appreciate
you for listening anyway I appreciate
the support from everybody else watching
all my other videos and subscribing
thank you thanks for liking the videos
and I will see you guys next time bye